foreign
wake up
[Music]
welcome everybody
to the 2022 H3 Halloween special today
we find ourselves at one of the most
haunted locations in all of Los Angeles
County nay
the whole [ __ ] country
here we are at
mentryville this is an old mining town
the family that made this place they
moved here father mother three beautiful
children one day day such as this
they all just disappeared
and the crazy weird thing is that their
car was here their belongings were here
everything is here that you would take
if you were leaving and yet all five of
them disappeared nobody ever found them
the menfil family entry bill
the mentryville family well just mentary
the mentary family yeah just the mentary
and then this was their bill what Dan I
think it's the mentary their name was
mentary and they made a bill you know
all right all right thank you
the mentry family they disappear they
disa [ __ ] period bro take a look
around you man this place is just crazy
Vibes Linda the Ghost Hunters with us
she of course was our guide last year
through the uh abandoned asylums yes yes
where we nearly made it alive hardly and
how does this place compare Linda oh
this place is much much much more
haunted than that place was really yes
are you just saying that for the video
not I was just in there it's very very
scary even for me really yes what so
what happened in there that was so
frightening so I took out the Mel meter
which you know I carry in my pocket the
settings went up to 67. that's that's
off the charts what's the highest rating
you've ever seen it's about the highest
really this is the main house they had a
farmhouse a school house their kids were
raised here they were taught here
they're all [ __ ] bucks papers
all Left Behind Zach how are you feeling
I didn't sleep last night and what are
you what is it you're afraid of what are
you worried about I just don't [ __ ] with
negative energy
right it's not my vibe do you consider
negative energy Linda is that an
appropriate description I don't feel
there's negative energy there's no
negative energy I feel that there's some
some lost souls here that we're going to
we're going to know tonight but I don't
feel anything any negative at the moment
things can change someone said that
people died here is that true but what
did I just say Bro you've been paying
attention
[Music]
they disappeared man they're all gone
bro joined us by a new uh ghost uh
Hunters with us Zachariah who is
he is a witch but not are you a warlock
no because I thought a warlock was a
male witch is that wrong uh warlock
means deceiver or manipulator and I
don't do that really because I Googled
it and it said what male version of a
witch yeah sure in the old old English
totally yeah but a warlock is a deceiver
which is a non-gendered term that a lot
of people okay and you're doing light
magic for us today uh I'm more in a gray
area for today though I when I
communicate with the dad or those that
are on the other side it's always out of
respect and reverence for their life
that they lived would you ever just go
in and be like man [ __ ] these ghosts and
see what happens I have I have in the
past when I've had to bless a house
because there was a really nasty
presence there
um and I did tell it to [ __ ] off we're
pretty great it left and so today
Zechariah is joining us we're going to
be doing a seance there and Zachary what
is this Seance so a seance means to sit
um you all you will sit and you call out
to the other side we're not just
community kidding with the spirits of
this property it might be some of you
here in this group anything that might
come forward from your life I don't make
any guarantees that they're going to
want to talk to us but I've already
heard footsteps when I was in there by
myself you did I did did it scare you no
it's kind of like okay I guess this is
gonna happen that's where my brain goes
is I'm like I have to mentally prepare
myself it's going to be a it's going to
be a ghosty evening do you think I think
so yeah I do yeah and Zechariah do you
speak with the dead what what is your
talent here are you a clairvoyant how do
you compare to Someone Like The Long
Island uh uh what's her name yeah the
Long Island Medium sensing the presence
of somebody's grandfather is anybody I
don't do that [ __ ] you don't do that my
is my [ __ ] artist thinks she's good
at Cold reading which is [ __ ] which
is a talent in itself though yeah but
that's not but cold reading means you're
not [ __ ] a ghost right basically
because I'm in the same realm I can't
talk [ __ ] about other practitioners
let's say hi to all of the crew members
let's take a look how you feeling
feeling great I'm not afraid
how about you baby
I'm feeling Marty McFly great they made
me be 11.
this is dude look how light them up
that's what probably looks good huh
you check the Dome Luminosity oh you
know what they you were getting
good score on the Dome Luminosity that
is very luminescent if I get scared I'm
gonna point this at your Dome I'm a
little spooked you are I am yeah okay
maybe a lot I don't know really okay but
you like being scared don't you Lena um
I like to throw yeah like going into it
but I do get really scared so okay and I
believe in this stuff are you afraid of
bringing back uh bad vibes like Zach
says no I I haven't considered that okay
yeah start thinking about that oh my God
I'm feeling okay
I definitely believe in this stuff a
little bit but I'm more I think
anticipating it then I am scared for it
okay okay I feel dressed to look for
like Yogi Bear more than a ghost I've
been doing this for the past three hours
I'm feeling good I'm feeling confident
um I'm feeling good I feel kind of at
peace right now I ran up that hill
earlier me to deal with God
I just don't want anything to follow me
back home
uh I have a pretty good life and I don't
want someone to [ __ ] that up you both
made a professional guarantee that Zach
is not going to get haunted you will not
get haunted yes at that and the [ __ ]
holder they might piss yourself but you
won't get it well from fellow's act to
another Zach like come on bro exactly
well that's my Hebrew name too yeah did
I let you down last year no not to let
you down this year Fernando is the park
ranger yeah and uh you're here joining
us to make sure we don't light it on
fire or what what's your
responsibilities here responsibility is
the safety of everyone be back safe okay
okay do you know anything about
supernatural stuff like what if
something goes wrong with the ghosts can
you ensure safety then
I I'm not you know I so you may not be
so you actually may not be qualified to
keep us perfectly safe then I don't
think so I like that all right and uh he
brought fireworks we were gonna lie
behind the house is that okay no but you
cannot do that thank you Fernando
um we'll try to uh leave this place uh
unburned please don't let's go let's get
started guys let's do this here we are
outside the barn this is where the kids
used to frolic and play
they left their Pony here
all that was found was a starved ass
[ __ ] dead [ __ ] Pony dude
and I'd [ __ ] and pissed itself
and that's all they found that was the
only sign of life that they found when
they came to the barn isn't that right
guys that's the story right wherever
your historian is on your team they did
a great job you you you're a very wise
man yeah yeah and so we're going in
we're going to go do our Seance right
we're gonna commune with ghosts
respectfully yes respectfully okay yes
let's go do it guys this is the original
condition these people they left their
paint and cement bags here and also a
Modelo can Zach you want to come explore
in here with me I don't know if I'm
gonna fit dude all right let's go up
okay
[Music]
so to begin
we light a candle for the living who the
[ __ ] is that outside seriously did
somebody run down there we'll start over
here I was like that's not going to be
good Fernando come here you're killing
the vibe dude
so to begin you form a circle
[Music]
light a candle for the living
means all of us here anyone who's
watching
because in the spiritual realm there is
no time there is no space
there is a device on the table here and
a device on the table here because we
also like to measure if what I'm saying
corroborates with those things but what
I'm going to do next is call in the
directions call in any of the helpers
and guides that might be here on this
land
and then light the next candle for those
who are on the other side of the veil
we're connecting the world yes so
everybody close your eyes
do me a favor and just take a deep
breath through your nose
audibly exhale through your mouth
[Music]
the Guardians of the East the fire
beginning in creation I ask that you
bring your presence and peace and power
into this circle hail and welcome and
then you say hail the milk
they'll say dead or that Ellen welcome
sorry
call to the Guardians of the South the
spirits of water protection peace and
Clarity hail and welcome male and
welcome and called to those in the west
the land of shadow of Earth and safety
hail and welcome hail and welcome
I called to the north the land of the
spirits and spirits of the air Aaron
well and welcome
everybody put up your hands
to all that is above and all that is
below and all that is within guide us
protect us and keep us
now light a candle for those across the
Veil
on the side
and we invite in any spirits that wish
to commune with us communicate with us
and speak to us I ask a question yes how
accurate is this the Beatles You've seen
where they do this
I mean some of it is you know it's
always a player reality right not to
interrupt but uh the rempod which is
down the stairs and there was not a soul
down there is going off on its own we're
getting a 5.5 reading so something just
entered oh really yes
and they came up the stairs so again we
State whatever is here may speak to us
come to us activate the devices around
us walk around us
yeah things going off what's going on
Linda the REM pod which is an EMF
detector which tells us if there's a
spirit presence coming our way keeps
that's the beep you keep hearing that's
what keeps going off down here you guys
both had a feeling that this place had a
lot of activity no question wow Linda
even got scared a little bit I did I did
in the main house
[Music]
Zach how are you feeling
blind
anyone hear that
sounds like an airplane that is an
airplane yeah the curse of living in
California you know just can't get away
from people
there are there is activity in this
corner
um
it actually kind of started before we
even called in the circle
um there was also the presence of a male
a man downstairs
it was just in the barn
not everything has meaning you guys gosh
you know I think that's what's funny
that's the funniest part about being
into the occult is everyone's like what
does it mean I was like it just means
just [ __ ] bugging I appreciate it
I appreciate you keep it real I call out
to those across the veil past present or
future that exist on this property or
this land we reach out to you and we ask
us we ask you to join us
communicate with us
there Linda was someone else supposed to
be here with you in your group today
one person right yeah do you feel that
yeah what do you feel about it just that
we're missing people I'm in person why
didn't they come today they're sick
um diarrhea
that's actually yes hey that's treatable
so that's great they'll be fine over
here Linda you gotta stop walking around
okay you're throwing or not okay I'm
sorry I'll stay still because the wood
moves once again we reach out and we ask
spirits that are here to come forward
and communicate with us come upstairs
and join us
well it's as if they're lingering on the
outside of the circle they're not
wanting to come forward and by day
there's at least three there's not much
happening in the circle right now
can you guys like Focus harder
and run the circle guys
does anybody have um this is a good way
to get it going to do you have any uh
questions or anyone that you want to
reach out to on the other side
how about you say their name out loud
grandma what was her name Audrey Audrey
are you here with us in this circle what
if we all chant her name really quietly
100.
[Music]
I come like Ethan's the only one here
everybody
um
it doesn't feel though that there's any
on things left on set or unresolved
issues I I feel like I'm getting some
weird energy behind me in that corner
over there that thing but the sheets
what is that
[Music]
oh my God
oh my God Dax Zach stirred something in
me that yeah nobody's good
I'm speechless dude that scared the [ __ ]
out of me bro I just barely kicked it
and it rolled maybe this will help lead
the Seance okay that's yeah Zach made
this so it has dark energy for sure wait
was that your intention was to make it
better at all dude you made it to look
like me
product of a disturbed mind Yoles
everybody sit back down it said uh it
put a is that the letter i or the letter
L is there a reason why this is here
maybe we should use it
you could Channel energy of spirits into
something that looks like a person yeah
and then you can utilize it to have it
communicate with us if there are any
Spirits here
breathe life into this vessel
laughs
give us your message
[Music]
let me charge and consecrate you with
magic
did you feel something my sciatic nerve
is acting up a little could that be
related this is open to receive and
embody any of the spirits that are in
this room and I'm going to use these
dowsing ones if they cross it means
there's a spirit present if they open it
means that there's something further on
the room
if you're here and you've entered this I
guess it's a dummy head that's my head
made by Zach it's Crossing
no okay
oh the candles flickering like crazy
dude
yeah does your name start with an i if
it does uncross the dowsing rods
bitching all right and they're pointed
right at you for some reason because he
made it wow okay
I knew that would be what are you
looking at me like that did you follow
Zach here is that why you're pointing
the dowsing rods at him or why you
crossed
oh yeah
yeah
you got you got a hitchhiker with you
buddy
is it like a good one or like one of the
like that like because some hitchhikers
are like rape they'll rape you and [ __ ]
and like bury you are you speaking from
experience and then well I'm just saying
and then some are like cool and they'll
drop them off cool man it's no he's
saying no cross across these rods if you
mean him any harm
God please don't cross
[Music]
maybe why is it going that way now
oh Olivia so wait you asked me and you
did ask if your grandmother was here are
you Olivia's grandmother cross the rods
if you are
I told her hey girl
I know don't don't put grandma on the
head
well whatever Spirit came with Zach is
now inside of this this
[Music]
from the north to the west to the South
to the east thank you for being here
thank you for joining us in this circle
until we meet again
goodbye everybody say goodbye good
morning goodbye Zach you're gonna have
to you gotta carry it nope you're saying
bro no I made it for you no it's a gift
what if you have to carry this dude I'm
already got the giant flashlight Zach
just take it
this is part of you when I when you guys
made these
careful don't don't drop it that's what
I was gonna say Zach when when you guys
made this
each one of them represented your soul
and spirit oh it did it yes it did it
was so obvious bro
I'm not holding it
no so just a lot to carry clear is my
grandma in her house
hey man I miss you
[Music]
you laughing at
what
was so funny
we moved to the schoolhouse because
let's face it the barn ghosts are
[ __ ] lame isn't that right Zachariah
they totally work they didn't want to
talk to us we're going to try the Seance
again also I noticed
it says Zach Lewis live at the
troubadour
that's pretty crazy did you write that
no dude whoa that's [ __ ] ghosts are
welcome sold out though
hail and welcome
welcome I'd like this candle for the dad
that they may see us come to us and be
guided to us
are there any Spirits present that wish
to communicate with us
if so please make a noise
set off any of the devices that are in
the corners they have all the lights on
them
there's an answer already
behind me thank you for responding to me
are you the spirit of a child
if you are make that device go off again
oh oh yeah oh there's a dark force
literally walking across
I don't know what that is but you can
see someone walking you can actually see
somebody walking
there's somebody walking
oh my God
does it change if I put a light on him
yes yeah
I don't I don't think this is a spirit
that is in our time
I think this is a residual haunting does
anyone here uh nobody wishes any of the
spirit's harm right
I do maybe he needs a little provocation
is he mad at me for joking around like
that not mad but more so just like be
respectful be respectful yes
um it feels as though he doesn't want to
communicate he just wants to watch so
he's a voyeur I guess spirit I
understand you don't want to talk
but are you connected with the kids that
disappeared here
goes here they don't respect you you're
wasting our time and you're [ __ ]
boring
but uh idiots glad you're dead oh
[Music]
you surprise yourself
let's see what's up
man well good you know what Pierre from
here you got what you wanted exactly you
gotta apologize now I'm not apologizing
the thing is he should apologize
[Music]
when I said he was observing us it was
because he wanted to make sure we
weren't [ __ ] around or disrespecting
the space so the fact that you did that
and then you got an immediate response
here with a different tone going off on
the device says a lot about what he
responds to what see
he doesn't like if you're disrespectful
he doesn't want let me say this so keep
doing it if you want probably the
teacher right but I don't need him
anymore let me actually Zachariah is the
one that told me to talk [ __ ] um listen
dude don't be so sensitive bro it's not
that serious you just want to have a
spooky [ __ ] video were you offended
by what he what he just said yes or no
I feel like you're not responding to us
he's telling you to [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off
I'm gonna go find a new house to hunt
[ __ ]
loser
your diet polio again
yeah
okay yes
did you die a dysentery you old-ass
[ __ ] loser oh Jesus no okay yo ghost
listen up if you are were alive in an
NRA building I would
all right
[Music]
are you gonna follow zacko no no no
you've Fallen Ethan home
not answering that I don't want to hang
out with someone they don't like is uh
is your name Edward where do you get
that name from maybe that's my middle
name my grandpa
yes Edward are you upset that people are
making jokes and swearing at you and
saying they're glad you died
foreign
but they wanted you to communicate with
them yeah this is all different now wait
something else come up everything is
going on yeah the candles it's okay it's
okay Edward
I don't know what is that he's reporting
our channel
that was that word I gotta apologize
he's going to blow them up okay I'll
apologize Edward
[Music]
I think Edward [ __ ] those murdered the
kids bro he said no what do I got to be
nice to him if he's a murderer though
you keep saying no add you okay all
right cool do ghosts lie
[Music]
do ghosts have bodies no or I just want
to acknowledge that we know your name we
understand that you wish to be respected
thank you for activating all of this
what's going to do about it
he's a [ __ ] ghost like okay you don't
like being disrespected what are you
gonna do about it Edward if you want to
leave you can
dude the only reason we got anything is
because I provoked him Batman bad
it says yes
then we're skinny back then sure
Ethan do you want to try what we did to
Zach last time where you have the
headphones on the side sure Spirit can
you please ask his name to him
I just heard my name I'm out man no way
yes so what you do is you pose a
question so Edward is there anything
that you want to tell Ethan now that
he's in here in there alone Edward was
that you pacing back and forth
do you not wish to talk to Ethan do you
think he's a schmuck
you're not getting anything Ethan I
heard it say doll
you're supposed to say that
all right okay okay I gotcha
let's start all over okay
Edward do you have any messages that you
want to communicate
three
three three there's three things you
wish to say what are they hi hello okay
that's mine what's the other one okay
is Ethan a schmuck answer that question
hello
hello it's scared
you're scared whisper
I'm scared of words I have to whisper
because game yes this is a game
well there was a kid in there too I'm
making this all up
what's your name Escape
is someone hurting you
[ __ ] swear to God
no [ __ ] way you're lying I swear to
God it said [ __ ] bro
did you
why
I don't think it's a kid saying bad
words no no
mountains yeah there are surrounded by
mountains yes we know
hated
School reject all rejected at school
Revenge
oh my God yo guys this shit's freaking
me out
holy [ __ ] should I keep doing more yeah
just just for another minute or so and
then we'll go to the house
are you tell
me slit
slit
he wants to cut Ethan's throat
like for real
Zach oh my God it said Zach
let's see
okay Ethan it's gonna murder you
okay in all reality if there is a child
that needs our help tell us a number how
many spirits are in the room right now
stop
all right okay we'll stop what's
happening okay we're gonna stop we're
gonna stop what happened
you answered yeah
[Music]
he said Zach but honestly I don't know
which one yeah sometimes when I work
with Linda it'll say witch so we know
it's talking about me that's kind of
funny
but there's two Zacks here so that's
kind of hard to tell didn't say which
dude
[ __ ] you Cam me and Ian are going to the
Porta pie
what you're very quick to come with me
to the porta potty I don't trust that no
you want to know why because you want to
kill me no no I went by myself earlier
and I've never been so afraid of my life
it's horrifying but you know what that's
what I get for being a good friend I am
willed your Will I Am will just getting
[ __ ] on by my friends
I I put the hat on and I
changed I changed you want to come in
BTS no no BTS no no BTS all right I'm
okay right now I'm a little nervous
about the house yeah I just want to go
in the hot in the house
[Music]
oh I didn't know who you were I was like
who the [ __ ] are you I'm scared dude
that last [ __ ] was so scary
okay after that close call with Edward
who said by the way he's following
Zechariah home not me we came to the
main house or was it Zach
we came down to the main house here now
this is where the family lived this is
the most haunted place Linda was in here
earlier she's got you got scared from
this yeah no question did you come
running out of the house no it's my job
it's your job yeah I gotta not be scared
now Linda you had mentioned that you had
the highest reading you've ever seen in
this house yes wow there's no
electricity right so it doesn't make no
it doesn't there's no way you could
debunk this even couldn't do bunker you
could not because there's no electricity
right there is power cables right there
there is there is but not inside not in
this house oh okay so we're all gonna go
in there we've got all these different
instruments that we're all going to be
carrying who gets the cat ball we're
gonna go scope out the area and then
once we understand what's going on in
there we're gonna go in one by one and
feel
by ourselves what's really happening
to be I wonder if this is one of these
places with an old-timey toilet
three movie Buffs out there what movies
are from would I see a ghost
all right guys ready everyone's going in
okay here we go
back yeah
we're in the country y'all
all right kitchen Ghost Hunters first
okay
[Music]
hey knock on this door hello
is anybody home so we didn't get a lot
of activity in this room but the one
over here that's closest to the porch we
did and then upstairs there's a lot
going on well they got in the fridge I
know I didn't open it
clean pretty clean dirty I mean not bad
my fridge okay so you know earlier when
I said I was in here
and I got the highest reading it was
right underneath that door frame right
there and it was a huge Spike so I think
we should head over there
communicate with you you know that
you're here
there's power in this building
hello hello
we came to see you
hello do you have anything you want to
tell us
um
[Music]
who's in here
okay let's keep walking because we got
some water damage up there yeah a little
bit yeah
oh [ __ ] this place is [ __ ] up
around around we got the word around
revealed raised he'll reveal himself
around yes upstairs raised
could you follow us in this room
someone in this room please make any
device go higher just to verify you're
in here with us
I just switched red
yeah thank you what does that one do so
that picks up on emfs just like the rest
of these everyone except for Ethan means
well come on
so we really just want to communicate
with you that's what we're here to do
[Music]
I'm getting like red readings is that
yeah you are you're actually getting
activity look at all that red should we
come in here let's go in here I think
they're calling us in guys we got some
oh there's a figure here there is the
window that's a window everybody in here
that wants to talk to us ah there's a
head so
um I got really scared from Ed Edward so
I did turn up the intensity of the light
a little bit just because if I get
scared I want to be able to see are you
the same spirit that was talking to
Linda and I earlier
cross them for yes
[Music]
what's the problem it's too [ __ ]
right
oh my God I'm scared bro
oh my god dude
all right guys let's go downstairs
[Music]
[Music]
did you hear that
yo did you guys hear that stop
you guys see anything over there you're
lighting up the mountains dude sorry sir
I'm gonna bring a plane down with that
thing yeah so we are here doing a Spirit
Bomb Spirit Box oh the Spirit Box yeah
okay similar to a ball but without any
violence whatsoever we're going to ask
questions I I encourage everyone here to
ask questions okay
is there someone present here with us
right now if so can you please tell us
your name
[Music]
always hustling bro oh you scared the
[ __ ] out of here
sorry guys all right let's start over
let's start go ahead is there anyone
here that's present with us right now
what is your name
I do hear you
mom
were you the mother that lived in this
house
I was that's a male voice
are you the father
of course yes yeah I am it's a whole
family present with us
who's in the other room
nobody that's a lie when they say nobody
that means something so those who do lie
Spirit do you mean that harm
[Music]
who is that
I think they just call you fat
[ __ ] did you kill your children
no
we thought we saw something in the
bathtub did you drown a child
[Music]
Spirit why why do you kill your own
child
what do you
so yo guys I'm sorry I'm getting spooked
you know I'm sorry it's just getting too
smooth
[Music]
eyes dude all right all right
that's so great does that like bother
you a little little girl how old are you
oh wow do you want us to tell you or
on the count of three everybody say your
name at the same time ready
one two three
wow
the coach said wow as soon as you come
in here by themselves give us a name
cam
wrong that's a cam Where is cam right
here I'll talk to the ghost
okay we were inside asking the ghost box
it asked specifically for Cameron by
name and so we have Cameron all strapped
up you've got the GoPro the ghost box is
that what we're calling it the face cam
and we're sending Cameron in there or
how are you feeling we're sending you in
there by yourself I feel great I'm the
perfect Unity between science and
Supernatural right now and I'm excited
to make a new ghost friend right now
you're a cyborg my friend cybernetic
yeah so so you're gonna go in and when
you hear stuff you're gonna scream it
out to us and we'll be asking the
questions out here and if you need help
just scream I will we'll be in in a
second all right cool awesome thank you
I feel great I feel like I'm gonna be
friends with the ghosts
this is very Steve of you I gotta say
hey thank you very much
okay
[Music]
wow
a little ghost okay so he's gonna yell
and then what do we want to ask first
um ghost sauce
ghost are you upset at us
British person rich person British
person good yes
how many spirits are in there with you
right now incredible incredible amount
can we get a number
how many of you are in the house
nine because should we be worried about
Cameron sooner dinner oh [ __ ] he said
sinner oh what sin has Cameron committed
go in
sex
is this or maybe it's a Sim he entered
the house requesting is it okay he's in
your house does he have your permission
no
that's not their house
why are you here
why are you
shut up are you here oh [ __ ] oh my God
what am I pissed off the ghost system
yeah you want Cameron to go upstairs
this
downstairs Cameron go upstairs go
upstairs yes okay
she's all spooked out we're like
do not
said no and do not again he's doing it
no go go go no it's good oh my God
all right all right ghost
sorry about the Twilight Zone
that's to leave
safe to be upstairs
[Music]
are you in pain
did someone hurt you are we not welcome
here
dude this thing is going crazy right now
man dude this thing is going crazy right
now man tell us what is it saying it's
it's just a bunch of nonsense
send Cameron a message that he'll never
forget
no no oh okay I tried
would you like us to leave your house
come
come does he want all of this
they're happy we're here because why are
you happy you're here do you mean well
or or evil
we're here we're here how many
one more one more damn it's gonna be one
more when he kills cam right now yeah
are any of the children that were in
this house here talking now talk
switch switch okay do you want us to
send somebody else in switch
no you want to do it switch now he's
saying switch now okay cab come out all
right cam come down
I'm running I gotta hear him he's
running out of there
no I got you buddy
that's stupid thing okay so we are
sending Olivia in there by herself we're
very proud of you Olivia thank you
you're stepping up to the plate how are
you feeling I'm feeling a little bit
nervous yeah okay well we'll be out here
I've been told that as long as I remain
very respectful yes nothing should touch
me is that right yes yeah I don't know
if I talk [ __ ] does that affect her I
mean we're a team player right so that's
what happens okay so Olivia good luck
we'll be out here
is this on Olivia yeah Olivia yeah
we're just like Robin and Steve dude
literally yeah
money
good luck guys
ah what the Ethan
good luck
wait they all stopped waiting for the
layout
so we just sent someone in there do you
have a message for us out here please
tell her
go on go on
we would like to communicate with you
what would you like to tell us God damn
God damn okay
[Music]
what else is there a reason you're
hanging out at this house
[Music]
a gasket you okay
wait like yeah are you okay Olivia
what
what
are you okay all good okay okay okay
ghost
what do you think about Olivia must
go must go there's a bat well that's
what they say there's a bat mommy mommy
do you think that she's your mom oh my
God
she's terribly freaked out
ghost be nice to Olivia she doesn't is
this a little girl talking to her what's
her name Mrs Mrs it's the misses of the
house yeah oh my God hey Mrs
it's your [ __ ] problem dude
you you she said oh my God okay I'm
sorry
good I'm glad it's not Olivia at least
come out come out come out what happened
a bat just crossed
their a bat is literally right past me
get out
get out spirit Spirit
who's that it's in there anyway it's in
here it went that way
it's right there do you see it yeah it's
flying
there's a straight up bat just flying
down here
[Music]
what happened what happened come here
come here
holy [ __ ] okay all right okay yeah
that's a rabies
yeah we gotta go guys that's not good
actually hold on let's do a group photo
first just real quick just real quick
got bit by a [ __ ] best real quick we
gotta take a foot it's fine
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]